[Music]
i would like to walk down the red carpet
and have the interviewers talk to me
about the choices that i made creatively
as opposed to
hey you're a female
yeah
and
[Music]
having been in a band i was recording
things and they weren't coming out right
and that was it i wanted to be in
control of what it sounded like
emily lazar is a mastering engineer in
its most basic the mastering engineer
takes either stereo or multi-channel
audio and prepares it for distribution
whether that be
making it sound the best on a piece of
vinyl on spotify
one mastering approach doesn't always
work for all of those different meats
but she isn't just any mastering
engineer she is the first woman to ever
be nominated in the category of best
engineered album non-classical
when that first grammy nomination where
i was for the first woman for album of
the year i was like completely in shock
and so i started you know trying to look
online to see if i could figure out if
that was actually true because i it
couldn't be in my mind
it just couldn't be mastering the
mastering industry doesn't always save
you from the inevitable
being female and being in audio in the
first place was a complete oddity
there's sexism there's ageism there's
there's all sorts of
things that happen and we're in a
culture now where you can speak out
i was not allowed really to speak out
before
i also had situations where
i had people
inject me into a situation because i was
a woman and because they thought that
that was like a cool thing to have a
woman in there which was also equally as
despicable
these things happened and i'm aware that
they happened but they did not get my
attention they did not suck me down and
i always try to
inspire
not just women to follow their dreams
i really believe that if you can see it
and make it happen
it happens and if you only see all the
negative stuff all the people who don't
want women or don't treat you like an
equal or whatever then you're going to
spend your life kind of focusing on on
that and i i don't have time for that i
don't have room for that i want to make
records and i don't want to talk about
why i can't
[Music]
you